so today uh i'm looking forward to this
discussion with yuzi about how hard is
it to learn
english and how can
students who travel to the country where
the language is spoken
best take advantage of being there sort
of two subjects
now uh first of all i want to remind you
if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe you can click on the
bell to get notification
now yuzi lives in england
he's from japan and a few weeks ago
i had an interesting discussion with him
in japanese
about language learning and i will leave
a link to that discussion
at his channel which is yuzi in hiragana
if you read hiragana or why uzz y
uh in english so uzi you are
right now in the uk right yep
what time is it there now for you um
it's 7pm
7 p.m okay it's 11 p.m here
so you know i i have done a few videos
about how
in fact i did one on how hard is
japanese actually not too long ago
uh it's very difficult for a native
speaker
to comment on how hard his or her
own language is so it's easier for
a learner to comment on that so uh i
wanted to
get a sense from you on how difficult
you found english what were the
difficulties
and also the role of you know traveling
to the country where the language is
spoken
how you were able to take advantage of
that so let me ask you first of all uh
you know when
did you start learning english and what
were some of the difficulties that you
that you were faced with okay so first
of all
um i started learning english english
since um when i was in first grade
in junior high school so which was when
i was
13 years old or somewhere around that
and because like i was in the i was in
the japanese
japanese junior high school the english
education wasn't too good
but uh my school um has a
like um i don't know how to say but like
it's a bit advanced in terms
of learning english right so yeah there
are so many for
um english teachers i mean for
um like people from abroad
so that we can we can hear
or like we can communicate in english
um some parts in our life i mean the
school life
right even though like i couldn't speak
english that well
at the time but yeah but compared to the
other people who
like live in japan and then there's no
opportunity to speak english
like i had the advantage for
yeah in terms of speaking english but
like
as i told you i couldn't speak english
that much but after i came to england
um since 2019 september
um there is no japanese in here so that
like
i can i have i had to speak
english and then i have i i had to
understand english all the time
so my english um progress so let me
interrupt you there so
you are living sorry interrupt so
you live what's the name of the place
where you live oh yeah
i mean it's covered which is the
northern part of northern east
so yeah it's it's quite far from london
it takes three hours by taking train and
there's a nice speech but like apart
from that there's nothing
to be honest yeah
okay and there's no other japanese there
no
i chose like um i chose the school with
no japanese
because my english
and and this is a school is this a
language school or is this a regular
school or
um it's like the local one the normal
normal school
uh-huh wow so uh
oh should i can i ask you how old you
are um i'm 17 years old now
okay so you're in a regular class with
other english kids
how was that experience yeah um
yes so my classmates like all
all of my classmates sorry
oh sorry um all of my classmates have
been educated
in um english for their whole life
so that they have like um right big
advantage
on like learning in english but for me
um i have been educated in japanese for
15 years of my life
so um i compared to them i i can't speak
english that much
like that well so at first
when i came here for the first time and
then it's been
first month i know a month or two months
passed
um i couldn't speak english at all yeah
but
after that like i've been progressing
and then
now i think um i'm able to
understand every single words no single
words but like i can
understand the class and i can um
answer the tests or exams so
yeah i think i've been quite well now
i you know it's interesting i think
comprehension is the most important
thing in language learning
yeah uh because once you understand you
feel more comfortable
yeah when you don't understand it's a
very uncomfortable feeling
to not understand what people are saying
and
your speaking gradually improves if if
you can understand you'll gradually get
better at speaking but
the first thing is comprehension what
did you find most difficult in english
what aspects i mean people say with
japanese people sometimes say you know
that the polite form is difficult or
that the
you know the particles like
that they find this difficult what do
you find difficult in
in english um
i think the most hardest thing
to learn english is i think
[Music]
maybe the mentality part like
for us like especially for japanese
people there
they avoid to speak speak or communicate
in english
and then everyone gets ashamed when they
make mistakes
so they right yeah they are avoiding to
speak english so that's why like we
can't speak english that much
and then but once you once you like um
you try to speak english or you're
trying to speak english
it makes um and you
actually can speak english like um i
don't know how to say it but
if you um yeah let me think of it
um it's been quite hard like um
yeah once you have the experience um to
speak english or
understand english you have more
confidence and then
um it makes you more uh it makes you
want to
improve your english more so that like
um your english would be right um yeah
very improved after that so maybe
you know i think yeah sorry sorry yeah
no i don't want to keep on interrupting
i just i was going to say that to me you
said two important things there
one that uh when i asked you what you
found difficult in english you didn't
specifically you didn't say it's the
tenses or it's
you know continuous tense or nothing in
particular
what you said was you just need to have
more confidence
and start speaking yeah and so you're
actually not
focusing in on any specific point of
grammar
and because you're surrounded by
english-speaking people
you're gradually understand more and you
gradually start to speak more and you
gradually don't feel
you know shy or or you don't lack
confidence
and and as you understand more and have
more success in communicating
you are more keen on on speaking
so so that it's not specific aspects of
the language
it's more the attitude of the learner
that's important have i is that
a fair uh assessment yeah
yeah it's it's like i i'm comfortably
agreeing with that
um i think like most japanese people i'm
avoiding speaking english
and because i think um you know
in japanese culture like it could be
said in other cultures as well
but like if you if you pronounce like
english right i mean
um let let me um come up with one
example
if i say um if there's a sentence that
um i have a pen
um in the japanese class i mean english
class in japan
and like normal japanese students say
i have a pen which is in japanese accent
but like if you try to say if you're
trying to imitate the english accent
i have a pen everyone's you know even
like everyone laughs so so
yeah no no one wants to try but you know
this is also very good
yeah i know but this is this is very
interesting because it's not just
japanese people and it's not just in the
classroom
the reason is that if if i'm going to
say i'm learning japanese
with a bunch of other foreigners to
actually to to
sort of throw yourself into the japanese
pronunciation
to pretend you're japanese to try to
speak with japanese
a japanese accent is a little scary
because you're afraid you'll fall flat
on your face you're afraid you won't
pull it off
and so it's safer to stay in
the the the sort of native accent so
it's safer to pronounce
with a japanese accent or if you're an
english speaker it's safer to pronounce
japanese with an english accent
and so a lot of people not just japanese
school children
a lot of people are reluctant to come
out of the safety
of you know pronouncing sort of with
their own accent that's very interesting
yeah so
uh but were there any um so so
again i don't wanna you know i'm trying
to what i hear you're saying strikes me
as something that i'm very familiar with
and that is that
we gradually get used to the way the new
language works
but but there are still some aspects of
languages like if i talk about
slavic languages then they have a lot of
fussy detail or nouns and adjectives
that change
depending on you know whether it's from
or to or by
and it's difficult to remember these
things when you're speaking
uh i don't know whether there are
specific
issues in english that you find when
you're speaking you're not sure whether
it's
this or that for example or or
you don't you don't think in those terms
um actually for me specifically um i
think
um the pronunciation is the most like
significant problem for me
like that at first like i have i had i
still have this problem but like
r and o
and l sound so which is like that i
think
most japanese have yeah this problem
but like um yeah so
i think this is the most significant
problem for me but
like for other japanese people i mean
the
food studying or learning english in
japan
they have the most
biggest problem for them is i think
listening
because they're not used to listening
listen english so they can't understand
english so that they avoid learning
english
right listening comprehension i agree
with you to me that is the
fundamental skill if you develop good
listening comprehension
your speaking will improve your reading
will improve your
writing will improve everything comes
from that because it makes the language
natural to you you hear it you know what
it is yeah listening comprehension
okay but it's interesting i've asked you
several times to try to identify
specific say grammar type issues in
english
and you haven't said that there was this
that or the other issue
and probably that's a good thing because
if the more we focus on specific
grammar issues the the greater the
pressure we feel
and the greater we are inhibited the
more we are inhibited
whereas if we focus on listening
comprehension gradually
our output improves because we're
listening to it
naturally and the brain is starting to
create
patterns that start to enable us to
speak more and more correctly
i think the other thing with regard to
accent
you know i was just thinking about this
when i hear someone who speaks
say english which is the language that i
can judge because i'm that's my first
language
who speaks english with an accent
slight even a fairly strong accent but
who speaks
well who uses the language well
who uses words the right word
uses the language correctly i'm very
impressed
if i hear someone who has very little
accent but who
doesn't use the language well that makes
a poor impression and
i think even in terms of any language
like if as for you as a native speaker
of japanese
if you hear someone speak japanese with
an accent but
uses the language correctly uses the
words correctly
does what's certain does that create a
better impression or someone who has
good pronunciation
but doesn't have a good vocabulary
doesn't use the language correctly which
is more important do you think
um i feel same as you but like to be
honest um
if if they speak japanese um i don't
um actually i haven't came i haven't
come across that situation that much
so like if someone speaks japanese i'm
i'm
like still impressed so but yeah
if i had to choose like one one like
one in the in two um probably i would
choose
for pronunciation with like with um
higher
no how do i quote um with
advanced um not grammar but like grammar
or
camp because like yeah yeah
it's like a culture yeah you know
right yeah they're in the culture that's
another such an important point if you
do a lot of listening
every time you're listening and reading
you are absorbing the culture
yeah you are getting more of a feel
those
other people whatever language you're
learning those other people
become less and less strange because
you're absorbing
through reading or listening you're
you're getting closer to them
and the closer you come to them the
easier it is to
to interact with them what has been your
experience
do you ever meet say japanese exchange
students who are in london where there
are more japanese people around them
and how has their experience compared to
yours
um so i've been only here to be honest
like in scarborough for
a year but like um i actually been to
london but for like the for the
traveling
for a week or something but like i met
um i met um people who have
um who have studied abroad in somewhere
not not particularly in london but like
somewhere in canada
or something in the us or uk but like
they
they have japanese friend in there so
their english is um was like better than
other japanese people
but still like they can't um they can't
study
like they can't learn in english so
they have like a a bit more
they're they have advantage in
understanding in
english but they can't use it more
advanced way
so they can just yeah speak a bit
english but like they have note that um
i don't know but they can't use that in
studying with something
so they just understand english right
yeah not more
than that so you
are 17. so you were 15 when you got to
england that's amazing oh wow your
parents i mean that's a
courageous thing to do yeah yeah how
long do you intend
how long i mean when you first arrived
you didn't understand anything i mean or
very little true
it must have been very difficult
[Music]
uh how long do you intend to stay in
england
um yeah like first of all like um when i
when i
arrived here um the school stuff was
there
and then they they welcomed me but like
they will come to me but like i couldn't
understand even that sentence that
like they're saying something good thing
to me
but i couldn't even understand that and
after i came to
after i go to the after oh sorry um
after
i actually entered the school like after
the first time has
started i actually couldn't understand
anything
in class right so i couldn't do
any um homework or i couldn't speak
to i can speak to my friend so i studied
hard but like
it's more like getting used to it so i
didn't feel that it started who are you
staying with
who who are you staying with i'm i'm
very boring we had a host family
no no boarding school so a boarding
house yeah
yeah oh it's a boarding school okay
school yeah
okay uh so so you
couldn't communicate you couldn't
understand and so you basically studied
and did you have special english lessons
to help you
catch up to the others yeah i i thought
i would have it
but like um they didn't provide that so
i had to
be in the same situation as the normal
like
british students do so that was quite
tough
[Music]
how long before you could actually
understand what was happening in the
classroom
um you mean the first first time
or yeah when you
you arrived yeah let's say
three or five percent i think max is one
does five percent
of the class okay but how how long did
how many months before you could
understand what the teacher was saying
or what other people were saying
okay um i think three months or four
months
to reach that i think 60 or 70 percent
yeah right and so
how long are you planning to stay
oh you mean further or from now
in england yeah how much how much longer
yeah i actually i'm leaving quite soon
um i have i see okay yeah i had the
biggest
exam into in these two years uh i've
been studying hard for this example like
the exam has been cancelled
because of the confidence situation so
oh i see yeah yeah
it was planned in may but like um it's
the council so
am i gonna leave here in march
yeah so a month or something that soon
yeah
yeah yeah
okay well that's really really
interesting
okay so uh what i take away from our
discussion is that
rather than trying to identify specific
things that might be difficult in
english
which creates some negative some
apprehension some
concern basically you've taken the
approaches
just let the language come into you
don't be afraid to speak
focus on listening comprehension yeah
and with that your language skills have
improved
so when you go back to japan you will
have missed two years of japanese
schooling how do you how do you overcome
that
um i'm graduating from disco which is
ib school international baccalaureate
which is the one of the
uh oh i said no more yeah so i actually
don't have to graduate from japanese
school so i graduated here
so i go to the university or
if i don't want to go i do something
else so yeah
okay well listen you see i've really
enjoyed this conversation thank you very
much
and as i said i will leave a link to the
conversation we had in japanese
uh i admire your courage and
by the way uzi has a very successful
channel on on youtube as
you will see my listeners if you go
there
and um i think this is uh there's a good
message here that uh
we shouldn't be too concerned about
what's difficult we should be more
interested in
what can we enjoy in the language and
let the language come into us
so anyway good luck to you yuzi
and uh thanks so much maybe we'll have
another conversation
next time in okay thank you bye-bye
thank you bye-bye